I am so uncomfortable right now recently
we made a video called men get
photoshopped into ideal male body types
it was a look at how Photoshop affected
us as guys what we weren't expecting was
this huge response that women have to go
through this every single day so today
we as men are gonna get Photoshop to the
standards that a woman would be
Photoshop we have been photoshopped
before but never like this
so in all honesty across media how much
of beauty is photoshopped like a little
bit all of it unless an ad specifically
says this has not been photoshopped I
can guarantee you that it has been
photoshopped it would be really cool we
live in a society where people didn't
have to alter their looks to be accepted
but that's not the society we live in
and it's been sort of this way for a
long time sometimes they credit it back
to cannot bear like a lot of people are
illustrating women instead of taking
their photos and they would exaggerate
the women's bodies to look like more
idealistic versions of themselves we're
constantly looking at images that have
been altered we only notice it when it
goes just a step too far
so what we're recreating today are
examples of disastrous photoshopping
correct your butt looks so much better
already
how so I'm gonna do the Victoria's
Secret underwear ad where she loses half
of her but how does a Photoshop person
do that I think that they were going for
a thigh gap why do people want so much
space between their thighs like
unfortunately body types go in and out
of fashion young women you know they
want to do what the guy says is hot
you're contouring my eyes so I'm doing a
Ralph Lauren ad what were they thinking
the Ralph Lauren and in Asia took this
ad photoshopped it to what they thought
was that was the ideal beauty standard
which is smaller which is very small I
were doing it I would probably slim your
cheeks a little bit more I'm even but
all my cheeks and in this context being
too big is what I think she was like 120
pounds or something you are painting my
face like the Joker I'm recreating a
recent Kim Kardashian photo people are
arguing back and forth whether she did
actually photoshopped image regardless I
think the Kardashians are kind of
notorious for always wanting to use
Photoshop and kind of look like the best
version of themselves what's going on
with the Madonna photo her before and
afters were incredibly different and
striking they took out her wrinkles
airbrushed and just crazy
the Madonna photo is your extreme case
of Photoshop Society cuts you off at a
certain age
and I think it's so hard for a woman to
age gracefully I mean I got a blemish or
two you're pretty [ __ ] up now really
after a while starts to infiltrate your
own psyche the sort of unrealistic
expectation of what was put out there as
a beautiful woman when really she
doesn't even look like that as a makeup
artist natural means a lot of makeup to
look like not a lot of makeup people in
the fashion industry know what's going
to look good on camera his face is just
a little wide so we're trying to bring
it a little bit closer I think that you
will learn a lot about what expectations
are put on you even from the moment that
you step into the shoes normally women
do already come prepared with everything
wax everything everything I think a lot
of people assume that a lot of it's done
posts a lot of work goes into making
people look at what they do for a cover
shoot oh this cream on my thoughts there
is a hook there's a brush on my butt
this is a this is a feeling wait so
celebrities like the Kardashians are
contouring and then getting professional
photo shoots done and then also
photoshopping just seems like a lot of
work I like they were ready for is that
how long was that say 45 minutes 45
minutes yeah ready pay my naked body
why are you touching me up yeah I
thought we already made me beautiful
just a little bit more I'm getting oil
rubbed on my body
well another man makes my butt look
better try so hard to know that you're
beautiful they'll start saying all these
things see that you're like whoa I
didn't even realize I had that as a
problem he's looking a little baggy
baggy are you kidding me this is not
untouched I've been touched a lot today
I've heard celebrities say that's like
an idealized version of me and they're
like I wish I was like that this is the
weirdest try to stick out your butt as
much as possible and aren't you back
move your hips a little back but not but
try not to point just well like if you
want it long it has to point bring that
towards us and push that you make your
butt tighter though but like not like
you're clenching I don't know what you
mean
back yeah wasn't it no I'm listening
it's hard to arch the back because I
feel like they must have shot this give
me a little sultry look but less mad
less like you're trying no like this yes
like sexy Gollum why has it doctor it's
[ __ ] can you look a little sexier you
look very scared right now I mean in
some ways I am scared right now I think
the most shocking part might be after
you see the Photoshop version of
yourself
you basically have seen what someone
wish that you look like I'm like a
massively contorted here I'm dying
how does Kim K do it it's so hard to not
let that affect you look more seductive
okay and you'll be fine okay this is a
hyper sexualized position and my face is
not a part of who I am at all in this
I'm an object my face won't even be in
the photo also think about this this is
their job to look good every day all day
I think we got it oh my god I feel
terrible I just felt so beaten down and
like there were expectations of me that
I couldn't meet the angular and heart
but be soft and be seductive but
innocent it's like what are you can't be
all of these things at once everything
you think is real is constructed
hopefully not in an artful way but it's
constructed there was nothing human
about that it's just an object
lit beautifully and now it'll be
photoshopped to look better
[Music]
and you don't have her ass no one has
her ass
[Music]
I'm both excited and very nervous let's
see the photo those arms sure did
strength
they look like string beans I bendy
straws for arms it's really weird but
the more I stare at this the more normal
you look yeah I'm getting really used to
it I know that I have a very skinny
person but like seeing them together I'm
like oh no we should take some of the
roundness off the BET now that I see the
one on the right I'm like I look chubby
as [ __ ] in the left oh yeah if you
imagine being a young girl having to
look at images like this since there
always will be Photoshop stay
body-positive with the current body that
you have and to know that where you are
right now is great so now we're gonna
look at the picture that I was
recreating are we ready to see Keith
2.00 gross I am a putty man I don't like
seeing myself like this I hate this you
don't like being seen as an object no I
don't want to be seen like a sex object
I want to be seen as like a fun person
but for a woman this is obviously not
realistic on the right but the underwear
looks nicer so they're not only
photoshopping my body they're
photoshopping the product so there's
like nothing true right even when you
look at Golden Grahams on a box it goes
like oh the Grahams look way better than
the ones in my ball and if one of these
women were to just release you know a
photo of just what she looked like when
she rolled out of bed it would be
considered brave as opposed to just
human Madonn
bleh let's see the Photoshop version of
this freckles that I have are what gives
me character I look like a vampire
also funny is that in an effort to
Photoshop you to look more like female
Photoshop standards your look is gone
from I will either murder or [ __ ] you
too
won't you please come [ __ ] me yeah and
then you come under fire when a picture
of you comes out that's not Photoshop
isn't like why does she think she need
to have so much redone on her it's like
well because all you do is tell her that
she doesn't look good enough all right
so let's see my photo as Kim Kardashian
sitting on your nuts yeah I was sitting
on my nuts it's like one nut up your
butt already we're not gonna talk about
it
like a sexy witch in real life or in the
after boat a little boat I feel like I'm
looking at a painting I have I have to
hang this over your fireplace Photoshop
is digital painting you are so
impossibly smooth I mean nobody's back
goes so effortlessly into their butt
like that because if you stood up you
would be a nightmare human one good
thing though is that people are becoming
more educated about the process and what
it takes to create these images and how
we fit into it as a culture and when you
hear another guy say something super
sexist or body shaming I'm gonna shut
the [ __ ] up go to hell
eat a dick you should know that all of
media is altered everyone's trying to be
better everyone's putting a better
version of themselves out there so you
can't judge your raw self with someone
else's affected self what's going on Kim
K is naked in the photo so I have to be
naked but to you know honor all the
people on set who should not see my dick
and balls I'm trying to put a sock over
my dick and balls not a big enough sock
huh right try guys know who covered your
nipples